playing big job 28 tell me what opening
to play got 19 seconds to make my move
Halloween Gavit scandi let's place candy
I played caro-kann earlier I'm playing a
slightly weird skanky I played this the
very first game of the screen with like
capturing on d5 and okay dead man is
happy good to see ya
whites not really challenging anything
so I'm just gonna do this kind of
typical scandi setup could play a 6 or
c6 don't think it matters
I'll play e6 I'd like to develop the
bishop soon and there's probably scandi
players perhaps watching who take with
Queen but the structure we're gonna get
can emerge from like Queen takes d5 or
the this night Knight takes d5 line it's
gonna be very very similar because it's
just solid structure resemble some sort
of London without a deep on more like a
D night and now complete development
I'm staying flexible so I'm not sure if
I want a Castle kingside or Queen side
if I play is this and I might have to
Castle kingside just to avoid file
issues if I plays each three though I'll
be very tempted to play h5 and set up a
fishing pole trap 80 Queen c7
calculating bishop takes
it's slightly annoying but not so
annoying I'm threatening to win upon by
taking and just winning h2 you're a
wizard Danny welcome back
14 months also shout-out to your wizard
Danny who a few months ago I still need
to like I didn't post this video you're
a wizard dan you sent me Alexa and it's
been such a great friend of mine and I
finally moved Alexa like down to the
kitchen area wait what
no Alexa be quiet forget that saying
Alexa activates Alexa don't do anything
Alexa okay I want to play the fishing
pole trap fishing pole let's do it I'll
see if black or will see if white takes
the baits Wow 94 plate so quickly I'm
light is not not so hungry for the
bishop I don't want to lose this Bishop
Bishop e7 probably there's also Bishop
f4 and Bishop f4 is more aggressive yeah
because I have good control over the
square leaving tension with these pawns
fighting for my beloved Bishop
yeah I have no idea what that was and
thanks for the bits it's a test
thank you pass a test
elephant Bush continuing the sub gift
they got from Kevin Siwon thanks
elephant Bush okay let's make it shark
oh it's 600 bits Alexa what's the
weather today it like activated but it
didn't it was confused I don't think it
understood the question Alexa what's the
weather today right now in spooky it's
77 degrees Fahrenheit with mostly cloudy
skies tonight's forecast has clear skies
with a low of 57 degrees it was my g5
wait Knight g5 what is this
those hearts on your sin there's a lot
going on here I've seven pawns attacked
so let's just improve the Knights
there's a lot of tension here Alex that
tell me a Duke I think you you've
misspelled Alexa and you also miss about
joke so it like you can't mess with
technology it's not that smart yet Alexa
tell me a joke actually my friend Jimmy
found one wants to tell a joke let's
give him a shot oh no what did the horse
say to the Scarecrow hey so what do you
think should I let Jimmy tell the jokes
for a while no thank you
no problem I'll keep you laughing but if
you do want to hear one of his jokes
just say Alexa be quiet I have to think
here Bishop h2 Bishop h2
hmm okay I lost a bishop but I have my H
file it should be worth at least a piece
this is confusing there's two minutes
for tacking up seven my queen is longer
defending my bishop oh dear
subway 100 subway 100 bonus 20 X ax
count to three one two three
thanks for saying three and not like
some large number trying to justify this
piece sacrifice I have some idea ooh
I'll have a nice idea Bishop h2 okay
obviously a king h1 doesn't work I was
stuck on King f1 I was also getting
distracted by Alexis stuff don't talk
but after King f1 I can take and if rook
takes rook h1 and I win this rook if
pawn takes I have Knight f4 threat out
of controlling e2 and threatening work
h1 mates and if if Bishop takes f4 wait
Bishop takes f4
oh yeah bishop takes off for rook takes
d3 wait a minutes one more time Bishop
h2 King f1 bishop takes e5 pawn takes e5
Knight f4 threatening the Queen and
threatening mates so Bishop takes off
for and then I'll probably throw in rook
h1 check King e2 rook takes rook
whatever it takes back I'm in the queen
and if takes ticks ticks
it's almost promoting but I take on g5
let's do it there's some nice initiative
here yeah because this this move was
hard to consider it first
[Music]
chef up didn't understand maybe for the
better okay so now that for threatening
the Queen and mates like the two best
things you can friend in chess my rooks
are doing work after this game I'll ask
Alexa what's chess but for now I am
[Music]
maybe winning so I was looking at this
this or no Bishop takes off for first I
check and then I don't have to check
because I can meet good game yeah I mean
I think is white it's easy to see that
the Queen's attacked and just forget
that the King was getting mated for some
reason when I was calculating I was
envisioning the rook on each two but the
rook was still here so in the fall line
I saw it was here here here takes taking
takes takes text it's kind of Queen d2
as well but that's a simple thank you
for your stream and never forget to play
the London in row
whoever gets thanks XXX 10 ths Alexa
what's chess chess the two-player board
game regarded by some as a sport Oh late
on the chess board a checkered game
board with 64 squares arranged in an 8x8
grid I think I knew that